alors quand j'ai vu votre spectacle jazz
et donc effectivement j'ai une troupe de
comédiens que vous convoquer comme ça à
tour de rôle d'une certaine façon non
voilà j'ai envie de vous dire comment
vous savez tout ça oui mais je suis
quand ça s'est réapprécié la glace ou le
travelo algérien il ya que d'un
personnage extraordinaire mais quand
vous étiez alger il ya deux ans vous
avez joué sur scène
alors j'ai eu très peur de le jouer à
alger ce personnage en fait je vais
arriver à alger j'étais super protégés
il y avait des mecs en fait juste avant
que je rentre sur scène qui avait
dégainé qu'ils disent et c'est bon tu
peux y aller mais là je dit c'est ouais
mais les premiers sketchs c'était comme
ça et pour je me suis un petit peu
détendu je suis quand je suis arrivé
j'ai dit j'ai un petit peu peur et tout
un mec m'a dit ne vous en faites pas la
voiture et bleury
là j'ai dit c'est pas possible et en
fait je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait une espèce de psychose autour du
spectacle de l'événement et quand je me
balade balader dans les rues avec des
copains algérois avait aucun problème -
et le sketch de chouchou pour y revenir
j'ai pas voulu le jouer mais quand je
déjoue et ça a été une grosse claque
les gens étaient très très émue s'est
inscrite sur la tolérance qui qui qui
parle de là des islamistes et où et qui
parle de voilà de tolérance c'est bien
la voir jouer la balle callaway c'était
important pour moi avant les personnages
spectacle à votre grand père c'est un
peu un tribute pour votre grand père
tout à fait c'est un hommage à la
décalage avec la modernité bien ce qui
m'est fait bien marrer c'est les un
procès vous demander au public de vous
donner des idées vous ramasser tout ça
et vous en faites un petit sketch tous
les soirs différents par les fondations
quoi alors qu'est ce qui revient le plus
souvent dans les demandes du public
mais moi j'ai le même thème tous les
jours je dis c'est un mec marche dans la
rue qu'est ce qui pourrait lui arriver
ouais et une fois sur trois le mec qui
tombe c'est négatif avec dit il se passe
quoi ils tombent et une fois sur trois
options par de djamel parce qu'ils
savent qu'on a bossé ensemble tout ça il
rencontre jamel et là je viens je
referme jamais là bas mais presque tous
les soirs il ya des choses qui
reviennent et des choses inattendues
c'est le seul moment où moi je ne sais
pas ce que je vais jouer le très complet
oui c'est assez gonflé je crois que
c'est une énorme prise de risque
oui je crois que c'est une performance
qu'on appelle à éviter de voir des
spectacles du genre en france où tout
est faux de dire voilà bravo vous êtes
pas ne fait pas de raphaël voix vous
refusez de revenir saluer non je fais
pas de rappel parce que le rappelle en
fait quand c'est organisé chorégraphié
ça m'énerve le mec qui dit bon là je
vais faire mon dernier sketch ensuite ce
qu'on fait là les techniciens je vais me
cacher deux minutes les mailles ils
applaudissent et puis je fais le plaisir
de ce genre faire un sketch derrière non
moi j'ai fait une fois un rappel dans ma
vie parce que vraiment vécu une
grossesse non là c'était dans une
c'était à montpellier
salut et montpellier c'est la première
fois que ça m'est arrivé où le rappelle
est indispensable c'est à dire que les
mecs ils applaudissent tellement que je
me dise si je parle comme ça c'est là je
me fais l'un tué dans la boîte le soir
donc le rappel systématique je trouve ça
dans les salles serait ce un peu
artificiel bien que le mec revient pour
faire son truc voilà il revient et puis
non c'est pas bien moins une fois que le
spectacle est terminé c'est un peu comme
la dernière page d'un livre
oh que c'est beau ça je sens qu'on les
verra je savais par l'émotion
on est dans l'émotion j'ai des musiciens
garder le mal et ce sens de
l'autodérision de reflets de faire
preuve de toute façon éblouissante et
est venu très tôt vous dites c'est de
famille on avait un regard décalé dans
la famille et chez vous ont charrié
beaucoup c'était culturel souhaitait
partir mais on s'auto charrier c'est
déjà culturelle dans l'absolu mais dans
ma famille c'était encore rester c'était
pire quoi moquer des gens qui venaient
visiteurs chaque fois qu'il y avait des
invités en fait avec mon frère on se
cacher on faisait les dialogues ont ces
espèces de doublage corédacteur on
faisait le mec qui parlait on ne partait
en vrille sur les discussions que
pouvait avoir mon père avec ces gens là
lorsque vous plaisait le plus quand même
c'était d'être le centre d'attraction
celui qu'on regarde sur tout petit déjà
voulu être au coeur de la lumière avec
les gens qui vous regardent qui
s'intéressent à vous ce qui n'a pas
beaucoup changé
non là que ce soir de ce soir pour
passer un bon moment
c'est irrévocable
vous êtes né à casablanca dans une
famille ni riche ni pauvre en 67 quand
la plupart des familles juives quitte le
maroc
votre père choisit de rester pourquoi
parce qu'on y est on y était bien et
parce que pourquoi les autres sont
bardées alors il faut leur demander
ebadi soit là justement
alors il ya un truc qu'on vous dit
toujours qui vous énerve
vous avez raison on dit votre père était
mime bientôt n'est pas été pas été pas
mine il savait faire du mime
il avait fait du mime ne vivait pas du
mime votre père votre père il était
agent immobilier il était vendeur de
sanitaires il était gérant de magasin de
jouets ouais c'est vrai que moi comment
tu sais ça oh là là là là comment vous
savez ça où
merci merci voilà forme il a marqué ça
c'est un vrai public de télévision c'est
vrai nom il a été il a été victime il a
vraiment fait il a vraiment fait ça mais
il n'a pas fait très longtemps c'est
tout ouais donc le répète parce que
c'est des raccourcis et des raccourcis
en même temps c'est vrai quand on vous
voit sur scène ou quand on vous voit
dans certains sketchs justement avec
jamel où vous dans ces conneries on voit
une gestuelle wes hérité de votre père
c'est évident que mon père et deux de la
gestuelle enfin tout ce qui est physique
j'adore quoi mais oui il a été mis sous
mes grands problèmes de communication
avec mon père ouais bah oui par les
marchés difficiles
ça veut dire fais gaffe tu veux t'en
prendre
la sig dont il avait les cassettes de
pierre dac chez lui c'est vrai qu'hier
dax 6 à 6 à aider à votre culture c'est
formidable c'est génial j'adorais ça et
lors la maison on parlait tous français
sauf dans les angles là dans les moments
de passion là c'est el arabi qui
reprenait le dessus dans les moments
d'émotion quoi alors vous étiez à
l'école française l'école georges bizet
saviez pas d'ailleurs qui s'était
vraiment georges bizet en vol n'avait
pas à l'époque
maintenant aujourd'hui je sais que c'est
un footballeur alors mis tellement
l'école que vous avez fait toutes les
classes deux fois il est resté très
longtemps comme ça tellement ça vous
plaisez oui attaché mais il y en a une
que vous avez fait même trois fois j'ai
adoré la sixième jeu la sixième ça a été
vraiment un moment pour moi dans ma vie
ou année après année on se revoyait
c'était vous n'arriviez pas à partir de
la 5ème arriver c'est pas bon alors bon
vous avez quand même un petit peu le
complexe des fois de l'autodidacte c'est
à dire vous n'êtes pas disciplinés pour
lire pour écrire enfin vous avez quand
même des problèmes comme le palais
l'école assez longtemps c'est dommage
vous n'étiez pas un complexe c'est plus
un complexe où en fait parce que j'ai
appris en fin j'ai appris que la culture
c'était autre chose que la que la
connaissance innée livre quoi j'arrive
pas à lire un bouquin c'est très
difficile pour moi j'ai du mal à me
concentrer
vous savez mais des fois même dans des
scénarios de films que je dois faire je
je je lis et puis je reviens trois pages
en arrière c'est ça me prend à peu près
trois semaines
voilà le film il est déjà fait ils ont
déjà pris un autre hacker
moi j'avais dit j'ai fumé elle dit nous
aussi alors en 87
vous avez 16 ans et vous partez au
québec
et là c'est incroyable ce courage qui
vous a fallu pour quitter votre maman
pour quitter le maroc pour quitter tout
sa maman oui voilà au québec
ben alors je peins ce cas c'est ça
qu'ils m'auraient tué moi vous savez que
vous êtes très regardées au québec sur
les je sais je suis le français que les
québécois aiment détester c'est le
format disque m'a dit julie snyder
alors là bon vous partez au québec tant
pis pour vous vous laissez notre bon ben
ouais ouais non mais c'était super pour
moi de partir à québec moi je vivais à
casablanca au maroc j'avais fait le tour
fav le fait le tour j'avais envie de
bouger j'avais envie de partir j'ai
envie de découvrir des choses et je vais
à j'avais envie d'aller en amérique quoi
je rêvais de ça et puis il y avait déjà
tombé sur la mauvaise pioche que c'est
non pas du tout pratique dit l'une
nous on était nu et tant qu'à faire non
non c'est pas comme moïse qui s'il avait
tourné un peu at on aurait eu le pétrole
c'est vrai qu'à force de regarder les
avions passé dans le ciel à casa je
souhaite monter dans un avion il va il
va montréal quoi voilà wayne jeux les
jeux les choisissez pas courageux c'est
inconscient voilà j'ai envie de dire ça
voilà je crois je crois qu'il faut être
servi récemment et c'est le bon terme
paraît l'inconscient voilà maintenant tu
veux dire ça tout le temps là tu sais le
faire
bon alors au québec vous faites la fac
de sciences politiques
ouais faut dire tout de suite c'est
beaucoup plus facile qu'en france ça
c'est pas du tout comme sciences po car
là bas tout le monde peut le faire
bon c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai je voulais je voulais rentrer
en droit et tous les mecs qui rendront
ils se retrouvent en sciences en voilà
tu veux à paris quand tu fais si on se
pousse ex top quand tu as des sciences
politiques c'est que texte alors
rapidement quand même gad elmaleh voulu
se tomber quand même la fac de sciences
politiques
non on vire à on vous vire ce qui est
quand même un exploit ah oui ça c'est
fort je savais pas ça et alors là vous
commencez à faire des petites choses
pour la radio pour la télé dans des
cabarets vous décidez peu à peu devenir
comédien une vocation née à montréal et
vous prenez conscience que pour vraiment
devenir une star folle à paris ouais
enfin je fais plein de petits boulots en
attendant way notamment un petit boulot
qui m'a qui m'a traumatisée ouais c'est
que je faisais dans un café à peu près
120 sandwich de jambon surtout vous j'en
ai jamais mangé ce cas par jour
la cdu la soirée télé pastrami ç'aurait
été mais là franchement est alors donc à
paris vous arrivez vous allez au cours
florent et c'est l'époque alors un petit
peu là je vois très bien moins jeunes
acteurs disant claudel enfin faisant
semblant dire claudel pas celui qui peut
lire claudel peut dire la vérité les
cheveux en pétard
pas rasé manteau noir vous répéter dans
les sales boulots aux grecs avant
d'aller voir des spectacles d'art gronde
vous dites bien chiant ce moment là mais
j'étais super leur relouer c'est non
mais ce passage était je croyais que
c'était ça le théâtre
ouais et puis bon il espèce de branlette
du théâtre aujourd'hui enfin pas
aujourd'hui mais depuis tout le temps
qui fait que que moi j'étais un peu
largué au centre accessible
alors donc vous êtes engagé à ce moment
là comme figurant dans les libertins de
planches à chaillot et la brévine balle
par mois et vous dit ça y est je suis au
top ce qui est énorme
shut up vraiment au top je suis octobre
à bout dit maman mais je vais vous dire
une chose j'étais figurant dans la pièce
je suis rentré sur scène j'avais un truc
à faire dans cette pièce a été je
rentrais avec un bougeoir au début c'est
quand même une performance d'aujourd'hui
au niveau de l'actorat considérable ma
mère était en pleurs quand il rentre
avec se bougent comme turbo moi je m'en
tiens mais voilà et donc sincèrement je
croyais que j'étais honoré ce moment là
voilà alors en 96 vous faites votre
premier one man décalage c'est un petit
peu une façon justement de combattre le
cliché du jeune comédien qui attend
qu'on lui propose un long épisode datant
d'à côté du téléphone vous dites vl ça
c'est bien aussi
ouais je vais les courageux ou
inconscient mais c'est bien je crois que
quelque part c'est courageux
je crois que là c'est courageux les
interviews maintenant oui oui oui et
puis c'est parti bon ça marche vachement
bien un spectacle très personnel prêt
personnel treizistes et biographe au
niveau graphique alors que celui
d'aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus
universel
ben
par leur balade
j'ai gâché le soir tombe bien après il
ya décalage après il ya la vie normale
celui qui s'arrête là et donc vous avez
joué trente représentations
exceptionnelles estime et il restait 1 4
l alarme et puis alors vous avez raté ce
sont des grands à l'ange blond il est
sympa il est beau un jeu vidéo
j'ai passé du courage ou l'inconscience
mais ça me plaît
alors gare à gand
maintenant bon vous allez arrêter de
jouer la vie normale c'est vrai à 330 x
salah bon et la cassette gel dégel et il
ya tout bon je vais faire quoi
moi je suis déjà en train de faire autre
chose je suis déjà en train d'écrire un
prochain spectacle et je suis en train
d'essayer d'écrire un film voilà les
chanter ça vous tente pas ouais moi je
vois très bien le chanteur et ses jeux
wii jeu j'aime ça ouais ouais vous
chantez vachement bien je crois que je
chante assez bien vous savez chanter ok
bon soir je fais aussi les mariages
départ me duval anniversaire waouh
ok je connais pas les paroles mais je
vais faire des sprints soit d'accord ok
ouais on va tout faire juste un petit un
petit beat comme ça la messagerie de
papier peint de la belle et au made in a
way
merci
avec eux
on
aujourd'hui
à